florida law
seeks to reign in large social media
companies this is an ap
story standing at a lectern
with a signed reading stop big tech
censorship republican florida governor
desantis signed a bill on monday that
seeks to punish social media platforms
that remove conservative ideas from
their sites the new law
will enable state to find large social
media companies
a quarter of a million dollars a day a
day if they remove an account of a
statewide political candidate and
25 000 a day if they remove an account
of someone running for a local office
desantis pointed out
in particular to them president donald
trump being banned by twitter while
still allowing
iranian supreme leader ayatollah
khamenei to maintain an account
when you de-platform the president of
the united states but you let ayatollah
khamenei
talk about killing jews that is wrong
desantis says
this bill targets social media platforms
that have more than 100 million monthly
users uh which include online giants as
twitter facebook but lawmakers carved
out an exception for disney and their
apps by including
that theme park owners wouldn't be
subject to that of course because disney
is in florida the santas has to take
care of us
so anyway so what do you think about
this i'm gonna go through okay here's my
initial thought and i'm the only
non-resident
of florida here so let me say this from
an outsider's perspective
and here's the thing um there's one
thing i think of desantis is
starting his campaign for president i
mean i don't know how much meat this is
gonna have but he wants to be the guy
out on the fourth there's no republican
out there that's
that you could think could possibly run
in three and a half years not one not
trump
i mean he's laying so low you don't even
know what he's doing right now i mean he
made big news the other day because he
hit a golf ball into the water on his
golf course that was news the other day
so i think desantis is running for
president i don't know how much meat
this is going to have
i don't believe that zuckerberg and
dorsey and anybody is actually shaking
over this
they're not worried about this one bit i
think it's on the surface it looks good
it sounds good
i think there's a lot of vagueness in
here uh ambiguity in here that you
really don't understand
how they're going to enforce it but it
looked good at the press conference and
it is especially effective
if you're running for president in 2024
which this gentleman will be doing
so you think he's going 20 25 i do i
can't you're going to see huge
announcements out of florida every two
months santas is gonna run
i mean he looks like a leader when he
does this and he's laying the groundwork
of what his platform's going to be
i think he's obviously eyeing the uh the
presidency but it's a little too early
to tell we got to get through the
midterms i mean we just got i mean biden
just got elected what uh six months ago
honeymoon's over
honeymoon's over we're breaking up find
someone to beat him yeah
i i would happen to agree with that but
i i think i've been pretty clear about
the
about big tech where even when uh major
williams was here i said look
uh trump's been banned from a lot of
these platforms twitter facebook youtube
everything
uh instagram he hasn't made an instagram
post since the insurrection
i think big tech is a little getting a
little too uh
big for their britches to put it apropos
speech
and i think this is something that needs
to be said
mark zuckerberg's and facebook's
approval ratings are in the 20 30
percent trump's at 40 percent
and i think this is something that's
good for sound bites like you said i
don't know how they're going to enforce
this
who's going to enforce 250 000 a day
how's that actually going to take place
send them an invoice see if they pay
yeah
what's going to happen how are they
going to actually police this thing yeah
how do they police that
i don't know all i know is i love the
idea you do and all i know is many of
the federal ideas start at the state
level
which means this may be an idea being
started now at the state level
when the next republican president gets
elected he's going to say we're making
this federal and i'm boom yeah then a
federal is going to get involved and
saying wait a minute you just said
you're a social media
company but now you want to ban people
if you want to ban political people you
have to get approval by us because now
you're involved with the government and
here's what we're going to be doing
quarter million dollars a day i can see
this smart uh-huh
when you explain it like by the way
quarter million a day right it's not
quarter million
a month that's three million a year
quarter million a day which is seven and
a half million dollars a month which is
90 million
a year that's real money just everybody
knows that is real money
when did trump get banned kai can you
tell me when trump got banned the day
after the insurrection yeah the 23rd or
something the 20 30 got banned okay how
many days since the 23rd
due to matter five months okay five
months what's five times uh it's been
four months or five
20 days something like that 120 days 120
days some 75 000
is what what's 120 days it's going to be
what 30 million dollars
okay 120 times 30 uh 120
times a quarter million
that's real money 30 million dollars so
twitter would be famous 30 million
dollar fine right now
okay i think they look at that as the
cost of doing business i don't think so
i think 30 million is a real number
you don't think so i don't ultimately
because if they can keep on doing what
they're doing and not change i think
they pay 90 million a year to do that
i do no i disagree with you i think when
you start when you start paying fines of
30 million 90 million
whatever the numbers are that's going to
get someone's attention i think
look big tech and their overlordness
is definitely becoming a problem and if
i'm a conservative and i'm seeing
conservative voices being taken down i'm
rallying around this idea right here so
big tech
has been censoring conservative voices i
think something that they did well
was disclaimers fact checks this has
turned out not to be true
i think that's all well and fair
especially when you're full-on
lying or quote-unquote the big lie but
to full-on
censor somebody and say uh-uh the
president can't be on this
this voice can't be on this at the end
of the day this is america we do believe
in the first amendment freedom of speech
you can't just completely
censor what i'm saying so what you're
saying is you like what he's doing he's
making noise and he's bringing attention
to a topic
i think he has a valid point because
it's got a lot of people concerned by
the way we have another person here
hodge's wife that just gave 10 bucks i
just like what she
quoted foreign eight is taking money
from the poor people of a rich country
and giving it to the rich people of a
poor country let me read that one more
time that's a ron paul quote
foreign aid is taking money from the
poor people of a rich country
and giving it to the rich people of a
poor country
she gets ten times ten bucks uh hodge's
wife sent us a text
three one zero three four zero one one
three two you're getting a hundred
dollars
i like how just is hodge getting any of
that money yeah haji's wife haji's i
don't know how to pronounce it okay
i hope you're listening by the way steve
levitz uh just gave a hundred bucks he
wants to talk about israeli army he was
in it for eight years
text us we may just give you a call yeah
i think it's all going to come crumbling
down for these uh
social media companies i really do
because now you're even seeing this and
there might be a segment later in the
show sasha barrett cohen is there a
bigger
liberal you know person that's more you
know socially
left than anybody else criticizing jack
dorsey for allowing the hate speech on
israel
they're getting high on their own supply
it's like a drug dealer that gets
addicted to coke
they're gonna make they're gonna be so
arrogant so cocky so out of control
now not much can happen until the
republicans get at least
one part of the government if they take
over the house in a year and a half i
believe
behind closed doors they are aligning
themselves to go
right after public enemy number one is
the big tech companies i mean you hear
about it right now i actually agree with
you yeah
and a lot more people are going on both
sides by the way yeah and something has
to be done
eventually and i think this is a
brilliant move by desantis because it
shows strength
it shows four-sidedness it shows
leadership and he can fall back on it
when he's running for president yeah and
he might even be able to push this
through in florida because he gets his
way here
good point yeah that's it
he's about to drop it i was going to say
that he has a mate
are you checking texts when he says have
they responded already okay so i want to
just call john real quick go ahead
i mean you may want to give me the the
vitamin phone as well so i can do
facetime if we can get that
and if the phone line is working i'm
going to cut adam off about seven more
times but go ahead
no it's hard to freaking argue with when
desantis says when you deplot from the
present united states but you let the
ayatollah khomeini
talk about killing jews that is wrong
who the [ __ ] is going to argue who's
going to argue with him
and they should put the pressure on but
here's the point answer the question i'm
not kidding
meaning dorsey answer the question
exactly they'll haul their asses in
front of congress
let me ask you a question how much does
sasha cohen
hate trump is it fair to say he cannot
stand trump a very fair is that a fair
statement
is it fair to say that he can't stand
giuliani with what he did and
julian is it fair to say that he likes
to go out there and mess with republican
politicians
is that a fair assessment for how many
years and and democrats he's messed with
i would say 90 percent is republicans
ten percent is them a fair enough okay
fair enough
you know who we just went after a couple
days ago who do you think just went
after
he went after jack dorsey can you pull
up the story with him because i don't
have it in front of me ky if you can
pull it up just pull up any story
type in sasha cohen let's not disrespect
it's fine sasha cohen h e
and and dorsey just putting uh jack
dorsey
doris there you go jersey he's gonna be
fine
okay all right let's go to fox news new
york plus go to
go to a new york post story go to a new
york post story so if you can make it
bigger so the guys can listen do me a
favor flip the screen let's go on that
real quick
sasha baron cohen blast twitter c over
social media anti-semitism
if you're giving me the phone okay got
it sasha baron cohen blast twitter c
over social media anti-semitism keep
going up
okay keep going up uh uh uh keep going
up keep going up
the surge in anti-semitism on the
streets is fueled by anti-semitism on
social media the borat
actor posted on twitter on saturday
tagging both the platform and ceo jack
dorsey
why do you allow hashtag hitler was
right question he wrote
those who celebrate the holocaust aim to
perpetuate another stop hate for profit
baron cohen was apparently reacting to
an anti-defamation league report
released saturday that said more than 17
000 tweets use variations of the phrase
hitler was right between may 7th and may
14th in seven days
that's 7 000 tweets and sasha baron
cohen is the same guy that doesn't like
anything about trump that goes after
dorsey so it's no longer becoming
a republican thing people are starting
to realize the power
of dorsey and how one-sided they are and
that's his homeland
israel i mean you could see how
passionate is about this how do you not
have an
algorithm that weeds out references to
hitler being a positive thing
how is that not in place you know they
have an explanation
that they have to make they have to talk
about where's dorsey he hasn't responded
to this at all how can you not say i
cannot believe that this has happened
under my watch we got to get this thing
fixed nothing
you know what and you got a few likes
for some from other celebrity trump
basher i think mark ruffalo
you know there's a few other celebrities
on board as well but there's another one
it's reprehensible it's unbelievable
actually this is
a perfect example of why you can't just
be uniformly
left or right you kind of have to just
use your actual mind
and when you see something wrong even if
you're not a big fan of trump or
giuliani or whatever the hell it is
when you see something wrong like this
you have to call it out like what jack
dorsey is allowing that's great
by the way here's the thing let me tell
you what i like i like the fact
what just happened right now with sasha
coming to me is the following
sasha cohen officially to me became a
true believer that he
really doesn't sincerely like the
policies on the right republican
policies which is fine
but he has policies that he also
believes in that he wants to impose and
is not afraid to ruffle the feathers
of the organization that's helping his
political party
moving agendas sasha cohen to me falls
in the category of a
jon stewart he falls in the category of
bill maher to me he falls in the
category of somebody tucker carlson
is not liked by republicans all the time
just so you know there's a lot of
republicans
that hate tucker but they like hannity
they cannot stand tucker so
you're seeing a lot of this taking place
and i think that's exactly what we need
today yeah and he addressed something
that isn't just politically
incorrect right that he was offended by
i mean there are jews being attacked
right now
in los angeles in new york all over the
country and this is fueling it
he has a legitimate beef dorsey has to
say something he literally does
i mean on the heels of what was going on
with israel and hamas you know for two
and a half weeks
um is unbelievable and you can just feel
the passion in that tweet as well
he's not done i'm sure he's you know
what else does he have to do he's
retired borat he's not going to be bored
anymore he said that at the golden
globes this year so
you know maybe he's going to be a
political activist we're going to see
you as a candidate for the presidency of
the united states
uh certainly not in 2020 you can
guarantee that
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you